we have seen over the last 20 years an
improvement in the mathematics
performance of elementary school
students that is faster and larger than
the decline that got everyone so upset
to begin with now what's odd is the
decline was called by people in the
policy world large alarming catastrophic
so on the increase has been called
stagnation I don't quite understand the
logic I think some of the people simply
do this who do they simply don't
understand the data but what we've seen
is relatively flat performance and
reading which is not as bad news as it
seems because international comparison
show that the United States is fairly
good at teaching reading we have seen
very large very rapid consistent gains
in performance in mathematics in the
elementary school moderate size gains in
middle school and then the bad news no
real games in high school so in
mathematics the bad news is not a
deterioration it's a failure to maintain
the gains that young children have have
shown as they progressed through school
that progress is eroded